While you're making a contribution to
the create your own adventure story, you
may find that your pull request can't
be merged because of merge conflicts.
Here's how that could happen and
how you could fix it.
Suppose you fork the original
repository on GitHub, clone your fork,
then make a change in a new branch,
and push that change to your fork.
In the meantime, someone else changes
the original repository on GitHub.
If there are merge conflicts
between their change and
your change, then your pull request will
not be able to be automatically merged.
Since there's no way to resolve
merge conflicts on the GitHub site,
you'll need to resolve the conflicts
within the clone on your computer.
To do that, you'll need to get the
conflicting changes from the original
repository into your local repository,
which you can do by adding a remote.
Recall that you already have
a remote set up called origin that
points to your fork.
But you'll still need to add a remote
that points to the original repository.
And many people name
this remote upstream.
Adding and fetching the upstream
remote will add branches like
upstream/master into
your local repository, so
that you can merge the upstream
branch with your local branch.
For example, I created a pull request
to add an option of stop, drop, and
roll to a page of the story
where there was a fire.
In the meantime, though, another
change was made to the same file to
add an option to turn on
the chocolate sprinkler.
That change conflicts with mine, so
I need to resolve the conflicts
before my pull request can be merged.
So in this diagram, this is the commit
adding the chocolate sprinkler, and
also this one.
And my change was to add a stop,
drop, and roll option.
These commits were the same
in all the versions.
Since I created my change in
a separate branch, I want to
make my master branch the same as
the master in the original repository.
So, I'll run git pull upstream/master
to update my master branch to
the latest commit from
the original repository.
Then I'll merge the master branch
into my changed branch, and
I'll push both the changed branch and
the master branch to my fork.
I didn't need to push the master branch,
but I thought it might be nice.
Now since this whole process only
contains commands that you've
already learned, I want you to try
doing this on your own before I
demonstrate how to do
it on the command line.
As a reminder,
the steps you'll need to carry out are,
first, add the original repository
as a remote in your clone.
Next pull the master branch from
the original repository into your
clone's master.
Merge the master branch into
your change branch locally.
And resolve any merge conflicts.
And finally,
push your change branch to your fork,
which will automatically
update your pull request.
If you run into trouble,
I'll demonstrate how to carry out
this process in the solution.
If you didn't run into this problem
because your pull request was
merged without conflicts,
I encourage you to get some practice by
making a new change and
then not making a pull request for it.
Then you can wait for
someone else to make a change and
then get some practice
bringing your fork up to date.
Even if there are no merge conflicts,
you can still get practice merging.
Once you've finished this process,
check this box